اقتحم نحو 400 من اليهود المتطرفين
واغلبهم من المستوطنين باحت للمسجد الاقصى
وسط حمايه من قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي وذلك
قبل ساعات من انطلاق مسيره الاعلام التي
ينظمها مستوطنون متطرفون وكان بين
المقتحمين لباحه الاقصى وزراء واعضاء في
الكنيست حالي
عناصر من الاجهزه الامنيه المختلفه ضمن
اجراءات استثنائيه لحمايه ما تعرف بمسيره
الاعلام ويتوقع ان تصل اعداد المقتحمين من
اليهود المشاركين في المسيره الى عشرات
الالاف وكانت شرطه الاحتلال اصدرت بيانا
اكدت فيه ان مسار مسيره الاعلام لم يشمل
اقتحام المسجد الاقصى بينما دعت جماعه
يهوديه متطرفه الى اقتحامه
معنى من جبل الزيتون في القدس مراسل
الجزيره احمد هزيم احمد اين وصلت هذه
الاقتحامات
سهام بين الفينه والاخرى تقتحم موجه من
جديد من المستوطنين اليهود اغلبهم
للمستوطنين على بطبيعه على كل حال اباحات
المسجد الاقصى بينما السلطات الاحتلال
اخلت الساحه كما تشاهدون من الفلسطينيين
وفرضت قيودا شديده على الدخول الفلسطينيين
الى البلده القديمه
وفرضت ايضا حواجز على على الطرق المؤديه
الى القدس الشرقيه بانتظار مسيره الاعلام
او ما يسمى بمسيره الاعلام في عصره اليوم
الاجراءات الامنيه مشدده بن غفير وزير
الامن الاسرائيلي دعا سلطات الشرطه
والسلطات الامنيه الى تسهيل وتسريع وتيره
دخول افواج المستوطنين الى باحات الاقصى
هناك توتر بخصوص ذو اقتحام المستوطنين
للمسجد الاقصى الى داخل المسجد الاقصى رغم
تحذيرات او رغم من الشرطه الاسرائيليه
بعدم اقتحامه وان مسار المسيره لن يعبر
خلال هذا عبر هذا الاقتحام لكن الجماعات
يهوديه كما ذكرت في الخبر ترجعوا الى
اقتحامه المسيره عاده مسيره الاعلام على
تم تدخل من باب العمود باتجاه الحي
الاسلامي ترفع الاعلام الاسرائيليه تؤدي
رقصات يقول الفلسطينيون انها استفزازيه
ويعتبرونها استفزازيه كما تقوم السلطات
الاحتلال باغلاق جميع المحال الفلسطينيه
داخل البلد القديمه خصوصا تلك الواقعه على
مسار المسيره
يجبر اها اصحاب هذه المحلات على اغلاقها
ومن ثم تصل هذه المسيره الى الحي الاسلامي
ترفع الاعلام كما ذكرت وتؤدي رقصات
رقصاتها السلطات الاسرائيليه ايضا سهام
شده من الاجراءات الامنيه على الحدود
تحسبا لاي تصعيد قد يكون هنا في البلده
القديمه وفي المسجد الاقصى في باحات
المسجد الاقصى وينعكس تصعيدا على الحدود
الاسرائيليه مع قطاع غزه او حتى مع لبنان
سهام شكرا لك احمد هزيمه مراسل الجزيره
كنت معنا من جبل الزيتون في القدس المحتله